I don't know if it was there that I
decided that even if I was going to die
and obviously I didn't I'm not afraid of
death the death is part of life most
people i have met particularly Americans
just are so afraid of death I don't look
forward to it at 85 I know it's just a
few years away but I don't fear it I
believe in the afterlife I believe in
warden punishment and I hope I'll be
rewarded I think some of all of that
comes from having served in the war and
I think serving in a war and seeing
people die also impacts on how you think
about other Wars so I believe that this
country has to be defended and there are
just Wars and certainly world war two
was such a just war but that the Vietnam
War was not and I thought that we
shouldn't be in it and I was march in
the various demonstrations against it I
believed it was wrong and ultimately a
huge majority of the people of this
country thought it was wrong and they
stopped it with their marches
well I think like most soldiers at the
time i served in the European theater of
operations and served in two campaigns
one for northern France the other for
the Rhineland and I fought in Holland
Belgium Germany I saw people killed I
was very frightened and often thought I
would probably die in Europe on the
battlefield somewhere but I didn't and I
came out alive i discharged as a
sergeant I think that being in a war has
an effect on your character outlook on
life and I don't recommend it there's
certainly other ways to to build
character but it's part of who you are
what you are